il y avait 23 mille spectateurs autour
de la pelouse du stade marcel saupin à
nantes
lorsque les deux équipes de france et de
belgique sont venus se présenter les
français joue en maillot foncé les
belges en maillot blanc et dès les
premiers échanges on s'aperçoit que ce
match sera tendue âprement disputé pour
deux raisons d'abord parce que le vent
souffle violemment en première mi temps
en faveur des belges et ensuite parce
que les récentes pluies en alourdit
considérablement le terrain le rendant
très difficile et contrôle de balle
étant hasardeuse gênant pour la plupart
des joueurs les belges comme les
français du reste pourtant les belges
eux plus fort physiquement s'impose en
première mi temps grâce à hasnon leur
capitaine qui rejouait au poste de ses
débuts demi et grâce surtout à l'ailier
gauche pays ce dans tous les tirs sont
dangereux grave surtout enfin au jeu de
tête des deux avant-centres claé scène
et de vries les belges domine avec
l'aide du vent les contre attaques
françaises sont le plus souvent étouffés
par les grands arrières centraux
belgique et son spa sarthe et place qui
est très normalement les belges devaient
ouvrir le score sur un centre de de
vries claeysoone sautait plus haut que
tout le monde au bourg manqué de très
peu de sortir ce ballon mais finalement
avec le poteau la balle rentrer au fond
des filets on jouait depuis trente-sept
minutes et les belges logiquement menés
par un but à zéro tel devait être le
score à la mi temps
en deuxième mi-temps changement de
physionomie de la partie les français
s'appuyant sur un vent toujours aussi
violents à les dominer et forcé le
gardien de but de bruges boon qui
remplaçait nicolaï a effectué de très
bons arrêts notamment sur des tirs de
michel qui fut avec le balsa l'arrière
gauche
le meilleur français de cette rencontre
avec herbin aussi en deuxième mi temps
tu restes les français surtout les
défenseurs bosquet au bourg qui tu es on
était bon très bon même alors que les
attaquants ne se faisaient pas trop
remarquer même loubet que l'on disait en
très grande forme et qui fut pourtant
l'un des plus dangereux avec revelli
les français devaient obtenir
l'égalisation à la fin de la partie à
six minutes de la fin très exactement
grâce à son capitaine
herbin qui trompait le gardien de but
belge bonne 1 but partout
résultat nul qui permet la france
d'envisager le printemps avec optimisme
en coupe d'europe des nations